[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pizza hut in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
at a pizza hut in the u.s the pizza size
that you want to get is often dictated
by the type of crust you want to get for
instance this right here is the smallest
you can get six inches but you only get
it with the pan crust in the uk our
pizzas come in three sizes firstly we
have this small
okay so they didn't actually have a
small pizza when we went because they
said that no one orders them and if they
do they normally just give them mediums
however a small is supposed to be nine
inches across in the u.s at a pizza hut
the only small pizza you can get is one
with gluten-free crust this one here is
10 inches the next size we have in the
uk is the medium pizza
this one is 11 inches across
the large you can also get in the hand
toss the pan or the thin and crispy
crust this one 14 inches
pizza in the uk also offers an
all-in-one pan box meal where you can
get a large pizza of your choice as well
as two sides and two sauces here in the
u.s you can get two box meal options
this first one is a medium pizza five
bread sticks and some dipping sauce and
then 10 cinnamon sticks with dipping
icing and it comes in one box
that really helps when you're eating
this in your car by yourself
[Laughter]
not big enough you say don't worry pizza
hut has got you and the family covered
this is the big dinner box
oh man
look at this dude it's like opening the
suitcase in pulp fiction
this looks
awesome you got two pizzas i got
pepperoni and i got sausage 10 cheese
sticks and you get an option of either
pasta or chicken wings get real get
wings in the uk we got these ones from a
restaurant and they gave us a portion of
six bbq wings not to be outdone we went
ahead and proved a point to no one by
going just a little bit further with our
wing size options you can get six you
can get 12
you know 18
or 36.
[Music]
lemon pepper nope i don't like that
who's getting the better deal for their
money well in the uk
a large cheese pizza will cost you 15
pounds 99 that's a price of 15 cents per
square inch
the u.s large hand tossed cheese pizza
is about 13.99 which is about 9 cents
per square inch making it about 40
cheaper than the same pizza in the uk
so here we have a large classic crust
cheese pizza
and a large pan crust cheese pizza now
these are the same price and the same
diameter we wanted to find out which one
gives you more pizza for your money so
what we're going to do is try and weigh
equivalent slices and see which one
comes out on top all right
we will
[Music]
weigh a large slice ourselves so pizza
hot large pizzas in the uk are supposed
to be cut into 10 slices but they've
actually cut this into eight so what
we're going to do is try and find a
slice that's the same size for
scientific accuracy let's wear a slice
of classic crust cheese and see what it
comes to
now let's weigh the pan crust
so our equivalent size slice of pan
pizza is about 103 grams similarly here
in the u.s this is the hand toss this is
the pan both large cheese pan
so one slice of pan is about 125 grams
hmm
the next one slice is almost the exact
same size
80 grams that's like significantly
less pizza same price uh yeah stick with
the pan look how thick that is versus
this
in the uk a large pan pizza should be
cut to 10 slices but ours is eight
assuming it was 10 slices each slice
would be 226 calories and that brings
the total for a large pan to
2260 calories in the u.s our pizzas
apparently are all eight slices
regardless of size so one slice of a
large pan pizza pizza is 360 calories
making the entire pie
2
80 calories one of these also contains
99 grams of fat as well as 3 400
milligrams of sodium
this entire pizza also has about 135
grams of fat 54 of those are saturated
fat which i'm certain is the bad fat it
also has
5.31 grams of sodium that in case you
didn't know punching
is 221
of your daily sodium intake don't eat
this all in one day it's got 100 of your
daily flavor in it
what about the most calorific thing on
the menu well in the uk that's a large
stuffed crust pepperoni feast
if it is 10 slices each slice is 292
calories bringing the total to 2920.
one of these pizzas contains more than
double your daily sodium allowance and
more than triple your saturated fat
allowance if you want to have even more
calories in your pizza then you got to
go with the most calorific pizza on the
pizza hut menu and thank you connor that
is of course the meat lovers this entire
thing is
3760 calories 400 of your daily
saturated fat 400
and it also is three times your daily
sodium uh if i not put a fine enough
point on it don't eat this
here's everything in a pan pizza base
from a uk pizza hut
wheat flour water yeast baker's yeast
rehydrating agent e190 vegetable
rapeseed oil salt premix salt calcium
sulfate emulsifiers e481
e472 e471 flower treatment agent e 300
enzyme alpha amylase xylonase glucose
oxidase protease cellulase sugar flower
treatment agent ascorbic acid e300 in
the us our pando has enriched flour
which is bleached wheat flour malted
barley flour niacin
furious sulfate and don't mess with that
sulfate he's pissed diamond mono nitrate
riboflavin folic acid water yeast that
contains two percent or less of salt
soybean oil vital wheat gluten sugar
enzymes absorbing acid sodium sterile
acetite
lactolite
i think it's lactolite now the uk list
might actually look worse but you
shouldn't be too scared of e numbers for
the most part the chemicals actually
exist in the us though as well but are
referred to by different names
for example e481 is just another way of
referring to the sodium steroid lactoly
also the e472e that's found in the uk
dough is otherwise known as datum and
that appears in the u.s hand toss crust
what about the marinara sauce well in
the uk it contains tomatoes citric acid
sugar oregano basil margaram thyme salt
onion powder maltodextrin yeast extract
rapeseed oil guar gum garlic powder and
silicon dioxide whereas our sauce
contains tomato puree which is water and
tomato paste maltodextrin salt spices
garlic powder tomato fibers olive oil
canola oil citric acid and natural
flavor so it sounds like it's pretty
much the same thing how about the cheese
in the uk we refer to our cheese as
mozzarella and it contains the following
mozzarella cheese salt lactic cultures
and potato starch it's actually pretty
short compared to the first two in the
u.s the pizza refers to as cheese as
cheese which contains mozzarella cheese
pasteurized milk cheese cultures salt
enzymes modified food starch sugar cane
fiber potassium chloride
excuse me
natural flavors absorbing acid
there is one thing to look out for on
the menu if you're in the us and you get
a salad the croutons contain
azodicarbonamide or ada this is a
substance that's usually used to make
vinyl foam plastics which form things
like yoga mats it's actually been banned
from using food in the uk since the
1990s
so this is my comment on the yoga mat
thing
it's always something even trying to be
healthy our salad has yoga matte plastic
and it's ridiculous like why do our
croutons have plastic in them just get
regular croutons without plastic it
doesn't make any sense
this peach is the bob dude that's really
good
[Music]
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk pizza hut i've got
quite a few exclusives and this are all
the exclusives you can only get at a us
pizza hut so i'm not sure if it's like
this in the u.s but in the uk pizza huts
operations are kind of split into two
halves you have a bunch of restaurants
where you will go and have a sit-down
meal and then you also have a bunch of
carry-out locations which just do
delivery orders the menus are actually
slightly different depending on where
you get your food from the brown ones
are actually from a sit-down restaurant
and the red ones are from a takeaway
restaurant we wanted to get a selection
of both to see all of the foods you can
get from uk pizza hut for what harry was
talking about before uh places for
carryout versus delivery only i have no
idea i just went on the website and
ordered it and this showed up so let's
start with the exclusive pizzas so
across these few pizzas we have pretty
much all of the exclusive customizations
available in the uk we'll start with
some of the doughs on the left we have
our gluten-free option i think there
actually is one of these in the us but
could be fun to compare ours looks
pretty standard from the top but my
personal favorite is here which is the
cheesy bites crust so instead of just a
standard crust they get twists of dough
and fill them with cheese and then layer
those around the outside here we have a
sprinkled kind of like herby cheesy
situation on the crust i've never had
this one before i think it's quite new
but it looks and smells pretty good and
then finally we have a vegan stuffed
crust option which is great because you
shouldn't be robbed of extra cheese just
for being vegan
right in the center here
is the u.s exclusive pizza hut pizza
it's shaped like a heart and it has all
the ingredients you only get in the u.s
went with the creamy garlic parmesan
base as a sauce the crust is a flavored
crust and i went with the hut favorite i
have no idea what that is and exclusive
meats i had put on here was italian
sausage meatballs and pork also has
banana peppers
shaped like a heart why it's all year
round and not just add valentine's day
is beyond me but apparently you can do
this
nothing says romance like a heart-shaped
pizza how do you cut that thing though
it seems like getting even slices out of
that would be an absolute nightmare
look what i brought alright so i guess i
will just do
right
[Music]
yeah no i hate that
now as it's becoming traditional on food
wars what we have here is a uk only
pizza this is a pizza with the cheesy
bites crust
with vegan pepper phoney caramelized
onions and rockets on it
it's actually not bad i'm gonna try a
cheesy bite as well because i feel
that's part of the experience
[Music]
i think this is the first uk only
creation we've made that i can actually
endorse it's actually pretty good
the vegan pepperoni i've got to say is
actually good
the texture's pretty much there it's
like quite salty a little bit of spice
to it and the cheesy bites like it does
make it a little bit harder to hold
because it's like
what are you supposed to hold on to but
they themselves are actually really
tasty
so yeah thumbs up for the uk only
pizza hut's most infamous menu items is
their take on the calzone aka the
pizzone p apostrophe z-o-n-e i've had a
pizzone before they're actually really
good i was
really bummed to find out that where we
are filming in this part of the united
states the uh los angeles california
area unfortunately the bazone is not
available when on the internet and sure
enough the zone is available at least in
st louis and at least in cincinnati so
if anyone watching united states would
like to ship mia pizone from their zone
plentiful part of the united states
please do um
i don't know how i'll get your high
address
now as you can see we have a bunch of
exclusive sides in the uk i'm not
entirely sure what all of these are
because some of them look very similar
so we'll have a run through and i'll try
and point out the ones i can identify so
at the back here we've got some potato
wedges i'm never really sure why
restaurants offer potato wedges because
to me they're just worse than fries in
pretty much every metric then we've got
a bunch of different chicken options
we've got these kind of like chicken
strip things here we've got these kind
of like spicy looking nugget things
we've got these herbie looking nugget
things and then we've got some plain
looking nugget things
as well as these like i think southern
fried bites apologies to actual southern
americans because i'm sure they are an
abomination here in america we have
something called wing street what i
understand wing street was a separate
business or separate restaurant chain
that is owned by the same brand
therefore you can get wing street wings
when you order from pizza hut anyway we
have a bunch of different sauce options
like we have a honey barbecue buffalo
which can be mild or medium or burning
hot garlic parmesan and of course
what was this one that i hate
lemon pepper which i don't like you can
also get a hawaiian teriyaki a spicy
garlic a cajun style dry rub or you just
get these bad boys naked ugh
worst time to burp there why do all the
wing street containers are like death
stars that seems like a sub-optimal way
to transport your food it's like a half
ball and then the lid is like another
ball sauce tuck
sauce talk you could also get exclusive
sauces on the side for instance blue
cheese
get yourself some ranch
uh cup of marinara and the buffalo
sauces of various temperatures honey
barbecue sauce sides of sauces we got
you covered uh outside of that we've got
some
nachos we've also got these like cheesy
bites which are just triangles of cheese
that get breaded and deep fried because
i guess cholesterol isn't a thing
anymore
we've also got some onion rings we've
got some corn cobs
we have cheesy garlic bread regular
garlic bread and we also have
mac and cheese but it turns out
you can also do that with mac and cheese
also wing street fries uh just orders of
fries that looks like you can get pretty
much the same
flavors as the wings when they toss them
in the same sauce these are lemon pepper
oh that's good
i don't like lemon pepper i'm finding
out something i thought every pizza hut
around the world had apparently not are
breadsticks looks like five sticks joey
we went over this in the papa john's
episode that is not a breadstick and you
can also get
cheesy bread which is like
breadsticks but they bake them with the
cheese on top of them this is the
chicken alfredo
is this just how they packed it there's
a buffalo sauce and a barbecue sauce in
here why uh these guys right here i'm
probably gonna pronounce them wrong okay
papa's like tater tots
yeah
we also have a bunch of exclusive
desserts at uk pizza huts if you're
eating a restaurant you have a few
options including one of these brownie
slices this is actually a vegan vanilla
cheesecake which looks and smells really
good i gotta say
and then you have a cookie dough thing
which usually comes with a little scoop
of ice cream as well and the desserts
huh we're almost done people
ah this thing right in front of me our
cinnabun mini buns this is the ultimate
hershey's chocolate chip cookie
if you're getting delivery from pizza in
the uk there are also some exclusive
options this is another sort of giant
cookie dough situation bites of ben and
jerry's cookie dough again it's usually
served frozen but they have now
unfortunately defrosted and then they
have some branded ice creams as well we
got their triple chocolate brownie last
but not least cinnamon sticks with a lot
of icing
you know i gotta do it
[Music]
see i always think that these look like
little tables for mice
you could just put the tiny slice on the
on the tiny table
and have a little little mouse dinner
party